- Hi, everyone.
Excited to be here.
Thank you all for coming for our session
about vulnerability
management in the cloud.
My name is Amos, I'm a
product manager for Tenable.
And before I start so
I know my crowd a bit,
which one of you, by a show of hands,
is familiar with Tenable
and Tenable VM
and Tenable Cloud Security?
Cool.
So let's start.
So what are we going to talk about today?
We'll start about speaking
about the challenges
and the different complexities
of vulnerability management in the cloud
and why is it different from
doing the same on premises?
We'll talk about Tenable
and specifically Tenable Cloud Security
and why I believe we are a
great partner for you to have
for the vulnerability
management program in the cloud.
And also about our brand
new, I think two weeks old,
Cloud VM offering that is really unique
and can solve a lot of your problems.
And obviously, we'll see it
in action with a live demo.
So there are many challenges
for vulnerability management,
but right now we'll focus on the cloud
and why is it different than
the standard challenges of VM?
So the cloud has unique workloads
with unique workload lifecycle,
especially containers.
Their images are stored
in container repositories.
They are spun up, taken
down. They're very ephemeral.
They change all the time,
which creates challenges of visibility.
It's hard to know what's going on.
And these visibility challenges
make it really, really hard
to operationalize agent-based solutions.
It's hard to deploy everything.
It's hard to manage everything
to create decent coverage.
So this solution basically
don't really work in the cloud.
On top of that, cloud
environments are very complex.
They have tons of different resources,
tons of different services.
Each one has its own configuration,
which creates a very non-trivial context
for the vulnerabilities.
And you must know the context
to prioritize the vulnerabilities as well.
So you have the challenges for the cloud,
but it becomes even more
complex when you combine it
with also managing
vulnerabilities on-prem.
It's hard to have one
solution to answer all
of these challenges and
the on-prem challenges.
So most solutions only do one of them,
so it's hard to solve both.
So we have challenges.
Why I believe we're a great vendor
to solve these challenges.
So Tenable is a leader
for over two decades in the
vulnerability management domain.
And why is that?
We have a really, really good
vulnerability intelligence,
which helps you prioritize
what vulnerabilities you need
to solve first.
CVSS isn't really good at doing that.
60% of CVEs have CVSS
that is high or critical.
So basically you can't
prioritize based on CVSS.
And with Tenable's
vulnerability priority rating
or proprietary scoring for
CVEs, it's more than an order
of magnitude lower than that.
So it's really easy to know
what you should do first, where to focus.
And you might ask yourself,
all right, what you doing there?
How do you prioritize?
So we take many different risk factors,
including knowing what real
threat actors do and where.
And you push all of these factors
into our proprietary
machine learning engine
and it creates a new scoring,
which is much, much more accurate.
On top of help you prioritize,
we also help you remediate,
we also help you remediate
efficiently with our plugin IDs.
What's a plugin?
A plugin is a grouping of CVEs
where we tell you that
with a single action.
What's an action?
Like a software update or a patch,
you can solve multiple CVEs.
So if we tell you if you
operate this version,
you only solve one CVE,
but if you do this, you solve
20 with a single action.
You obviously want to start
with solving 20 CVEs at a time.
And it helps you create
a more efficient remediation program.
So for over two decades,
we did great vulnerability management,
but in the recent years,
Tenable also became a
very important player
in the cloud security market
and the exposure management market.
So let's talk a bit about
our cloud security solution.
Just one sec.
Yeah, so Tenable Cloud Security
connects your cloud environment
or cloud environments,
even multi-cloud environments,
and basically reads everything
and help you create an
inventory of what you have there
and where your risk lies over there.
We look at everything
from IAM configuration,
data assets, obviously vulnerabilities
and create a unified view of the risk
and the different context for everything.
And why should you care
even if you care mostly
about vulnerabilities?
We can take a look at this.
You can see the toxic
combination over there
with the red rectangle where you can see
that we don't only show
you vulnerabilities,
we show you the context.
We take everything we learn from the cloud
as a context for vulnerabilities.
If you read the first one, we tell you
that you have critical vulnerabilities,
but these vulnerabilities
are also on workloads
that face the public internet
and they also have high privileges.
So these are the vulnerabilities
you want to solve first.
Obviously they're much more
important than vulnerabilities
and assets that don't
see the internet at all.
And once you know all of your cloud risk,
you want to push it into our
exposure management platform,
Tenable One, recently selected by Gartner
and Forrester as the number one leader
in exposure management.
And what's exposure management?
You have many, many different
tools I assume that collect
and analyze risks in different
places of your environment,
cloud, on-prem, OT, whatever.
And you want to have a
centralized single pane of glass
to see all the risk.
And this is Tenable One.
We normalize the information
and create a unified risk view.
So we'll see it in action a bit later.
And now I'm really, really happy
to talk about our new offering.
As I said, it's only two
weeks old, for Cloud VM.
Why did we build this offering?
So we talked to many VM professionals
and they told us, "All
right, we understand
what you're doing in the cloud.
Your CNAPP cloud security
platform is great.
We see it provides a lot
of interesting insights,
but we want to start more focused
on vulnerability management.
So we may get there a bit later,
but we want more lightweight solution
that only solve these specific problems
and we listened and we did it.
So Cloud VM is lightweight solution
focusing on vulnerability
management in the cloud.
What use cases are we trying to solve?
So first of all, you
have assets in the cloud.
You want to know what
vulnerabilities they have.
We do it relying on the
same vulnerability database
that we talked about before.
We can support migration
from on-prem to cloud
because you want to have,
during this process,
it can be challenging to
have a view, continuous view
of what's the current state of your risk.
And with this offering, you can do it.
And once you have a hybrid environment,
you want to have a single pane
of glass to see all your risk
of everything from your
on-prem environment
and in the cloud with a unified view.
So all these use cases are supported here.
And now let's dive into the offering
and what we're doing there.
So in the cloud, two
major types of workloads,
VMs and containers.
Containers are more standard,
more similar to on-prem.
So we'll focus on containers
that are more unique
to the cloud.
Containers have a unique lifecycle.
They start as a Dockerfile
in your code repo
then you build the image
and push it into a test
container repository,
container registry, you test it,
and then when everything
is good, you push it
to your production registry
and into production.
And we believe that you
need to analyze the risk
and to surface it as early as possible.
You don't need to wait to
runtime, you need to do it
as shiftless as possible
because it's easier to fix.
So our solution analyzes the
risk from the test registries
all the way to runtime
because you always want
to check also all the way
to the right because this
is what's actually running
and maybe you missed something
when you scanned the registries
and you want to see
what's going on in there.
So let's dive another step inside.
We do all of it agentlessly.
As I said, agent in the
cloud is problematic.
It's how to deploy.
So we scan without an
agent, you just connect us
to your cloud environment
and it's very short.
It takes minutes.
And we scan the workloads,
both VMs and containers.
We create a comprehensive
software inventory.
And from the inventory with
the vulnerability database,
we create a list of all
the CVEs that you have
in your environment.
On top of doing the runtime analysis,
we connect to your image registries,
the container image registries,
and we analyze them.
So with the Cloud Connector,
we can scan ECR repositories,
but we don't stop there.
We can also connect to third-party repos.
You can connect that there,
provide the relevant permissions
and we can read the images from there,
but also correlate them to
what we found on runtime.
So it's not separate.
And once we have all
of the information from
all the vulnerability
that we found in the repositories
and in runtime, we combine it also
with our exposure management
platform to combine it
with the vulnerability
findings from other places
in your organization, not just the cloud.
We'll see it again in
a demo right about now.
Yeah, so now let's see it in action
and I'll apologize in advance.
The video controls are a bit challenging,
so I hope it goes smoothly.
But if not, bear with me.
Oh yeah, you see, I told you.
Yeah.
Yeah, so here you can see the dashboard.
Oh yeah, you can see the dashboard,
you can see the different trends,
you have here how many
vulnerabilities do you have
in your environment?
You can see the MTTR analysis
based on the severity.
And on the bottom,
you can see different
aggregations by different factors
of the vulnerabilities we
found in your environment.
So you can see the inventory.
Here we first focus on the
container repositories.
You can see here the list
of many, many different
repositories we're connected to.
Let's click one of the images
and see the findings
we found on the image.
We'll start with vulnerability findings.
You click here and you see a full list
of what we found on this image,
all the vulnerabilities, a
lot of information about it.
We don't stop with vulnerabilities.
We also scan for malicious
files we found there
on the image.
Here you can see, for
example, Metasploit files
that have no business on
being on production images.
And we found them on this container.
Now, after we saw findings
on container images,
we can see findings on actual
workloads found on runtime.
Here we look at VMs with
vulnerabilities in them.
You can see we found many resources.
We'll choose one of them
that has vulnerabilities
and you can see an overview
of what we found there on this workload.
Here, again, a full
list of vulnerabilities
on this runtime workload
and the full software inventory,
whether vulnerable or not vulnerable.
And if you find malicious files,
you can also see them there.
And the next very important
view is a full view
of all the vulnerabilities
we found in your environment.
You can filter them, for
example, by a specific account
and by severity.
So you can focus on the
things that you really want
to solve first, high and
critical vulnerabilities.
And not only that, for
example, let's take the case
where your sister called you, told you,
"My friend told me
there's this new attack,
new vulnerability, it's called Zerologon.
Are we impacted?"
So you can go here,
look for the new threat by name, Zerologon
and you see where we found
it in your environment.
Yeah, here you can see
the different scores,
both VPR and and CVSS.
Here you can see the
different risk factors we take
into account when calculating the VPR.
And yeah.
And at the bottom, you
see the real-world events,
the different things attacker did
that impact also the severity
and the trend over time.
The VPR can be reduced
and then increased according
to the real-world events that we found.
You can also view it as a timeline
and if you click it,
you get more information
about the event that we're talking about.
On top of that, you can
also search by CVE ID
and see the information
about the specific CVE.
And you can see the impact
it has on your environment,
where you found this CVE.
You can see the full
list of all VMs impacted
by this vulnerability.
And also all container images
and also software packages
that have this vulnerability in runtime.
Now we're moving to Tenable One,
our exposure management platform.
Here you see a unified
view of the exposure
of the risk you have across all
of your environment, not just cloud.
You can see also OT, web
application scanning,
whatever sources you have
for risk and vulnerabilities.
But you can also look
at per exposure type,
per category, per source.
You have also unified inventory
of all of your assets.
And what's really, really cool here
is that you have the AES,
the asset exposure score
that normalizes the risk
for all your assets into
one prioritized list,
which is really nontrivial
because usually you must
go to different tools.
They say this is important.
They say that is important.
How do I know what's most important?
Here you look at this with this score.
And once you have this
unified score for everything,
you can create programs
that take into account
risks from different places.
So let's look at cloud migration
that we mentioned before.
We can tag some resources
as related to migration,
some from the still on-prem,
some already in the cloud,
and they are tagged.
And once they are tagged,
you can create a card,
it lets you monitor this
program, this project.
Here you have an overview.
You can see the custom view
we created for this project,
for these tags.
And you get many metrics
that give you very, very deep visibility
on the current risk and
the trends over time.
And where the risk lies,
whether it's still on prem
or is it mostly on the ones
that already moved to the cloud.
And you can see a dashboard
that you can really customize
to show whatever you want,
to follow different metrics
you really, really care about.
Cool. So this is the demo.
And before leaving,
let's focus on the things
that I really want you to remember
once you leave this meeting.
So I talked a lot. So these
are the most important things.
So yeah.
If you haven't already,
you really should do vulnerability
management in the cloud
because it has vulnerabilities.
You should get ahold of them
and see what's important,
what's less important.
When you do it,
it's really, really better if you do it
with a unified program for VM in on-prem
and in the cloud.
And to do it, it's better
to do it with a vendor
that has really deep expertise,
both in vulnerability
management and in the cloud.
And I think we're such a vendor.
Remember that we have a brand new offering
for vulnerability management in the cloud
that is lightweight, that is
first step into the cloud.
And if you want to hear more about this
or anything Tenable, feel
free to come to our booth, 251
It's just click over there.
So I'll be there and
other people will be there
and will be happy to answer
any of your questions.
And I'll also be around here
if you want to ask anything now.
So thank you very much.
(audience applauding)